here's the example that I'm asking us to
look at yeah because I've just shown you
ten minutes ago but three broad ways of
approaching inequality proofing like
this this kind of sticks out like a sore
thumb
right what can you do with this I'm
going to need to differentiate it's not
I should point out it's like a really
obvious just yet that I need to like
inter differentiation and not
intervention is the way to go but you're
side to get a bit of a feel for like oh
this is much more much easier to work
with versus this okay just as a general
rule go go towards differentiation
integration there's probably going to be
a number that appears because you
evaluate some kind of definite integral
like a PI appears somewhere like that
which comes from doing you know some
trig functions but here you just got the
functions themselves and then you get
given a domain restriction okay so the
easiest way to think about this is to
say well don't think about this thing
and this thing is separate things think
of them as something together and
understand how that's working
so whatever the introduce is consider a
new function
okay and the function I'm worried about
is just what happens when you combine
these two together X take away x squared
take away this guy okay now pause for a
moment before you embark on actually
doing in calculus where are we handed if
this is my function what do I want to be
true about the function if the original
inequality is true okay good because
I've just subtracted this from both
sides right so essentially what I'm
aiming towards is X take away x squared
take away log 1 plus X I want that to be
negative so therefore I'm going to use
calculus to get there okay so let's just
do the easy thing let's differentiate
this
can you read it off for me
-
outside it's an adventure
okay otherwise it won't work
be fair debate take away what was this
on the end good I'll just simplify this
okay now if what I want to do is show
that yeah this thing is going to be a
dreary sing function go down from some
point then I need to be able to say
something about this as a whole pit's
but it's all kind of in in separate bits
at the moment yeah
oh sorry that what there yep
yeah but so in order to understand that
behavior of this derivative I've got to
stop it being like a pile of things that
are unrelated to each other I need to
put this thing together okay so what
would you like me to do to combine these
into the one how about a common
denominator so for example this I can
view as one thing I can put it over 1
plus X when I multiply the top and
bottom by 1 plus X I'm going to get one
takeaway x squared right and then
there's a minus 1 are you happy about it
that's ok I get a tiny bit of
simplifying there okay so this is f dash
this is my derivative
okay now courts in mind all the things
you know about about functions about
sides and that inequalities that kind of
thing the first thing you know is hey
look at this guy up here I mean I'm in
real land right I can say therefore
negative x squared is going to be less
than or equal to 0 do you agree with
that in fact I can go one better than
that
how do I go one better yeah sir I
actually can't get to the border hello
right because I'm going to do that thing
again x squared is equal to zero if and
only if X itself is zero right but I
know that's not the case because it's up
it's a positive number right to zero
speed xquery ok so that's good that's
the numerator what about the denominator
what can you tell me about that it's
always positive right because you start
very positive number and you add
something to it it stays positive
therefore what you've got here is me
it's a question that you're saying it's
the product of negative number and a
positive number so therefore
- X is less than zero for all the values
in the domain it's worth pointing out
not always less than zero right can
someone give me a value for which this
thing is actually positive yeah if you
have a look at this right have a look at
the function okay where does this exist
well this is all real values this is all
real values but this guy was he yeah
that's right so he actually has
different values that he's okay for so I
need this restriction that they gave me
to be okay all fine so now what am I
going to do with this I know it's a
decreasing function but so what
which is still there
I've established is decreasing but so
what remember where I'm going and I'm or
where I'm going I want to show using
this derivative then this thing's always
going to be negative right that's what
connects me back to the original
question okay so I already know it's
decreasing but that doesn't tell me it's
always negative okay so I have to know
okay it's decreasing but if it's not to
like a hundred and then it decreases
well it's got a whole bunch of values
for which it's still positive right I
need to start at a particular place
right so where does it begin where is
this function starts at F zero all right
because remember decreasing is going
from left to right left to right I know
that I've got positive value so this is
like the beginning I actually don't even
need this particular value I just need
everything after it okay so what is f of
zero so I've got zero take Y zero
squared I'll tow you so that's zero
takeaway zero takeaway log of 1 which is
also zero okay so now I've established
the function starts at zero and then he
just starts dropping and it came out
slowly or quickly he drops I just want
to know that he does okay it's never
even there no stationary points either
do you notice that so it has to be
coming down so therefore here's the way
I worded it right i misreading you
probably want to take pay attention to
FM X is decreasing
all values of X in the domain that's a
corner
but it's not just decreasing it's
decreasing for all values of X in the
domain starting from this value that we
just determined all right so if you
start from zero you drop down right that
means you're always going to be negative
because you just started at one and drop
down there'll be some days you're
positive so therefore f of X is less
than zero so what was it X take away x
squared on to take away so then I just
have to add to both sides
okay